voilà la maison sans racines enrichi
mais d'abord vendre votre ville quand
même un mot sur vous disais tout à
l'heure vous vous êtes vous est né à
elne et en l'egypte saison physicienne
et d'origine libanaise ça veut dire que
nos familles ont émigré vers l'egypte
dans les années 1840 visites sur se
sentent à peu près donc d'origine
libanaise né gip sienne et puis je suis
venu m'installer en me donnant votre
langue à cette cct français dans la
famille à cette époque là enfin c'était
un choix on avait choisi la culture
française et on parlait surtout français
j'ai été élevé dans des écoles
françaises et mais je parlais aussi
l'anglais parce qu'à l'époque on parlait
beaucoup de langues différentes visites
j'étais bil'in d'enfin français et
anglais je parlait l'anglais de manière
à peu près équivalente mais j'ai formaté
toutes mes études en français ne devez
pas plus arabe je parlait l'arabe parlé
mais ça je n'ai je ne savait ni lire ni
écrire mais au journal arabe égyptien
oui mais vous auriez pu citer un moment
entre l'anglais le français à certains
moments j'ai écrit mon premier livre en
anglais d'ailleurs un livre de poèmes
j'ai écrit des poèmes en anglais j'avais
une passion pour la poésie anglaise
comme je dis oui comme je suis j'ai
shakespeare kitsch à l'aise et je
pensais que la langue anglaise était
très adaptée à la poésie donc j'ai écrit
les premiers ont fait mes premiers
textes en anglais
et puis ensuite j'ai écrit les deux
langues mais sans traduire j'écrivais ou
en anglais ou en français
et puis je suis joue il désire 2
vivre ici de vivre en france et 2 dès
que je suis arrivé ici alors j'ai
complètement optait pour le français bon
ce roman il y a c'est une ville que
c'est beyrouth et c'est une date je
trouvais très important c'est 1975 c'est
juste avant que que le pays bascule dans
la guerre civile et il ya une
dramatisation très belle de votre livre
sur ce qu'ils aient une place au fond
tout se passe autour d'une place oui on
racontait ce qui se passe
oui j'ai évolué d'abord au tome j'ai
très peu vêtue au liban étant je n'ai
pas été depuis des années je pensais
qu'il je voulais commencer par la veille
des événements
il ya quelques quelques feuilles
spasmodique qui qui font sentir que les
choses vont éclater et j'ai beaucoup de
mal avec ce livre je mangeais beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup hésité parce que vraiment
c'est difficile d'écrire quand on est
loin d'un tel drame
et tout d'un coup l'idée de cette place
m'a permis de ma permis d'avancer dans
au milieu de ce drame j'avais
l'impression cesse un gramme se passe en
fait à deux jeunes femmes une musulmans
les chrétiens qui essaye de se rejoindre
pour se rejoindre parce qu'elles sont à
la veille des événements ils ont
l'impression que si elles peuvent parler
un même langage que les choses peut-être
pourront s'arrêter et au moment où les
essais de rejoindre ya un coup de feu et
elle faisait que se rejoignent sur la
place et de espère que tombales dans les
bras l'une de l'autre
tout d'un coup à la fois les les les
arabes et les européens
cette communauté se les rejoindront
malheureusement au moment il ya un coup
de feu est l'une des deux tombe jamais
on ne sait pas laquelle
c'est ça y'a un témoin que cette femme
c'est avec qualiac y voit ça de sa
fenêtre est qui et qui au moment où le
drame se passe elle descend indécents
sur la place pour essayer d'aller à leur
secours et le roman se passe dans cet
espace et trois en espagne durant cette
marche
en même temps vous raconter c'est la
saga d'une famille le
dispersé puisque abbey road on trouve à
la fois la grand-mère métiers d'art et
habite paris et sa petite fille qui
vient de new york
ce sont des familles qui ont été misés
depuis de longues années et qui sont un
des racines très ténus avec avec ce pays
mais en même temps très tendre à la fois
et vous n'avez pas l'impression que le
fait qu'il n'y ait pas plusieurs langues
dans ce à beyrouth en le liban est une
des raisons de ce drame terrible parce
que la langue on en parlait tout à
l'heure elle unifie les gens les
rapproche des uns des autres mais je
crois que tout le monde enfin la langue
de base et elle a rappelé paul enfin on
parlait aussi plusieurs
je ne pense pas que le languedoc séparés
et non ce sont des choses plus graves
qui sépare je pense que ce sont les ce
sont des fermetures de communautés ce
sont des dés
comment dire ce sont des visions plus
plus fanatiques hélas mais ce je ne
pense pas que ce soit là je pense
qu'alain de base et elles en veulent
l'arabe mais c'est un roman désespérés
non je ne pense pas que je vais dire il
finit enfin en tous les cas pour le
moment la situation a l'air désespéré
lorsqu'on regarde ce qui se passe on a
l'impression que ces désespérés
je crois que l'espoir est toujours là et
que ces gens sont toujours de mouches et
j'en espère toujours et je crois qu'à la
fin d'ailleurs à la fin de mon livre y'a
quand même c'est une image simplement
c'est une couleur mais qui veut dire
l'espoir quand même c c'est une charte
qui s'en va les qui s'ils gardent un
oeil toute la clarté tenace du matin qui
faso qui s'envole de nouveau quand on
vit ce roman ça c'est l'actualité qui
intervient on ne peut pas ne pas penser
à mon confrère kaufmann qui est
prisonnière sous dit il est victime de
la même absurdité des mêmes éléments
tragique là la pression qu évidemment
que ça va tellement loin que le convoi
que plus clair et que même je vois des
amis qui arrive de la barre l'impression
que vraiment ça dépasse le possible et
on
on ne sait plus exactement ce qui se
passe mais je crois qu'à l'intérieur de
tout cela les jeux ce qui alerte au pic
enfin le une parole de paix où une
parole de rencontre je crois que c'est
celle là qui peut ouvrir des voies
nouvelles et jeu il faut continuer à y
croire